[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
perhaps the moon knows a secret of the
new sound
[Music]
let us begin our quest
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cabinets in governess gonna get out will
it get out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right I'm sorry we're live I'm not
hearing you there a quarter black Gera
two three four there we go good to go
Audio wait are we good we didn't hear
you is half asian lawyer bill Richmond
is his mic live as well it is okay all
right listen this is this is something
that's a little bit more impromptu so we
are live I can convert matter can say
that and I'm not lying
yep biggest biggest story we ever
released and I started with a lie we're
live no wait what okay so we're live now
so that for the last time before I dive
into anything here and because I
genuinely worried that this stream and
content could be taken down I ask that
everyone watching right now please tweet
Facebook Instagram post this wherever
you can include the hashtags YouTube
twenty20 election blacklist and Crowder
exposes YouTube I know that's
self-serving but we want to make sure
that people know where to go to find the
stream we are live streaming to the
blaze TV right now in case the feed gets
cut and I want you to know that I
expressly give permission for anyone out
there to screen record and pirate this
stream in the event that it's banned and
this content removed if this what's that
what's going on there I can hear you
don't worry about alright just keep
going so it's going to take a little bit
to sort of unpack but let me state on
the outset that I and the team here at
at lot OS Crowder have uncovered what I
believe to be undeniable proof of Google
and YouTube's current meddling in the
United States presidential election
directly I want to be clear so there can
be no misrepresentation regarding the
information I'm going to present again
please tweet Facebook get this trending
what I'm about to show you is what I'm
about to discuss it's not a left or
right issue we've heard that so much
it's become a cliche but it really does
affect anyone who believes in fair and
honest elections okay let me work
backwards understanding that I am going
to get to photographic and
videographic would I believe to be
irrefutable evidence of altering the
fundamental landscape of the election
let me start it backwards
many of you remember the vox ad
pocalypse okay that was a time in which
this program was a target of a
selectively edited smear campaign from
the company Vox and it should be noted
in in which the parent company NBC
Universal Comcast they have at least a
34% ownership stake the event actually
the controversy went all the way up to
the top of YouTube with Susan Wojcicki
herself even commenting on the story
publicly was at the recode conference
yes something like that should be noted
publicly sent stating that we had not
violated any guidelines so while we were
found to be in no violation of YouTube's
official policies or guidelines in order
to appease the leftist torch mob we were
completely demonetized on this channel
meaning that we would no longer be able
to sustain a living on the platform now
it should be noted that behind the
scenes during the Vox had pocalypse
might half-asian lawyer bill Richman who
will be here in a second to speak about
this more with me him and I received a
phone call from YouTube representatives
who refused to give their name or any
additional information outside of a
pre-written statement we were told that
they had extensively reviewed our
channel in full and that the violations
with the channel or the I guess not
necessarily violations but what it was
that we had done which warranted D
monetization let's go there's no
official term for it but the detailed
follow-up would be sent in an email so
that we could attempt to rectify the
situation andrey monetize ourselves this
is all we ever received we have the
email up right here so despite multiple
follow-ups asking for the promised
details youtube went to complete radio
silence again i'm explaining this so you
understand the backstory when we get to
the evidence that doesn't involve me at
all directly you two went to complete
radio silence
we even removed over 50 videos that are
now available exclusively for mug club
members at the blaze yeah even though
they didn't list 50 videos that could
potentially be a violation we took our
shirt
out of the merch store to be on the safe
side we continued to reach out by the
way all the while to youtube to complete
radio silence and I this is not a sob
story your support and joining Michael
it was so overwhelming we more than made
up for the losses and D monetization
very quickly so I really appreciate it
with support that we
then and we would absolutely welcome now
for those who haven't joined consider it
especially given the information without
to reveal there's no promo code or like
that you just search mug club and um we
would appreciate you joining here's the
thing D monetization is never what
really bothered me so let's get closer
to the issue that we're about to discuss
here it was a canary in a coal mine if
you will I
I've opened said many times I would
gladly take D monetization for the rest
of this program's lifespan if it
guaranteed that the organic reach and
the search algorithms were corrected and
they were transparent because and this
is central to what I'm about to release
here while money and politics is
important and it's an issue more
impactful and more valuable I would
argue in 2019 is information I would
actually argue that we've reached a
point where big money in politics it
doesn't doesn't wield nearly as much
influence as the mechanisms of
information or informational delivery in
2019 it's how Donald Trump was elected
despite being opposed by many huge
donors by the way huge Republican donors
and it's how many fake stories run by
traditional media have been exposed it's
important because at the same time that
D monetization was occurring with us all
of a sudden our organic region traffic
on YouTube was decreasing specifically
more specifically the gaining of new
subscribers in a daily basis everyone
here we did a complete overhaul we would
dig into our analytics we tried to see
what was happening the odd thing was
that on an individual video per video
basis our views were better than ever so
was our retention so is the amount of
time viewed so are the overall
interactions on videos all the most
valued metrics for video algorithms
according to YouTube's own statements
what we noticed was a drastically
reduced reach in in search and organic
traffic despite having really created
the kind of content that we always had
in the kind of content that YouTube said
they always wanted I'm gonna grab some
well I don't know if guys can hear a
little parched going up against the
biggest company in the history of ever
it makes me a little nervous this little
makes me look I don't really get
starstruck but this one has me sweatin
not quite sweating blood like Jesus in
Nagas M&E
you know guess something is that we were
talking yesterday all right okay listen
I just deal with discomfort through
jokes and they're usually worse than
other jokes I give you this backstory so
you understand how it is really that
late-night host in a comic was able to
stumble across some information that
will be shared in this broadcast it is
only because of all this tomfoolery if
you want to call it that if I may on
YouTube that we had begun digging into
the potential reasons for it we were
watching everything like a hawk we were
continually running effectively
comparative studies analytics testing
firm controls on a daily basis behind
the scenes because of all that
transpired so I want to note it's at
this time where we discovered some very
very odd I guess some peculiarities we
can say in simply trying to find one of
my own changed my mind videos an
employee here realizing that it was
likely faster than combing through the
archives himself our own video channel
because it's not necessarily the most
robust platform for that on YouTube he
just ran a youtube search steven crowder
changed my mind and nothing nothing
showed up which we thought was odd and
so we ran some other similar searches
again nothing now when I announced this
publicly we received responses from you
numbering in the high five potentially
six figures many viewers K we're
receiving the exact same results many of
you but a lot of you accuse us of lying
or doctoring photos because our content
was showing up as normal in your search
results
which didn't make a lot of sense to us
noticing a trend then on a hunch
my wonderful brilliant and terrifying
researcher reg he ran some controlled
experiments if I may using different
VPNs and that's when the puzzle pieces
started coming together the blacklisting
of this channel and its content on
search was occurring in the United
States exclusively let me explain that
what that means that means that if
someone searched steven crowder changed
my mind and argentina or any other
country the appropriate content showed
up if someone typed the exact same
search in the united states nothing
now we found or we were sent proof of
this many of these examples from from
countries all across the world ADA was
concerning for several reasons okay not
only because it provided a direct answer
as to why the organic reach had
plummeted but more importantly if this
is the number one conservative leaning
channel of all time on YouTube okay one
with a vast majority of our fans being
in the United States and one that is
hosted not not just a few but many
national presidential candidates as well
as political figure heads this week I
think we have Rand Paul on the show so
why would you tube do this how could it
be an algorithm and this is going to get
to more of the direct evidence of the
current election but I want you to
follow the story here this is why we are
in a unique position to uncover this
didn't intend for it to happen we just
wanted to find out what was what was
screwy about our channel so how could it
be an algorithm and if they were doing
this by the way to the largest we were
thinking the largest conservative
presence on the platform YouTube
despite in their own words having found
they found no violations of policies in
our part what could this mean for the
political landscape of America more
specifically the 2020 elections okay I
expressed these concerns in a in a cell
phone video a flippant cell phone video
making sure to communicate that at the
time I didn't have any evidence
available to me of this occurring to
anyone else but I encouraged everyone
out there to send in your own test
results and I also express my concern in
potential election engineering so this
is several months removed from the Vox
ad pocalypse a cell phone video after
this for the first time since the Vox
said pocalypse I was immediately
contacted by YouTube and this time not
by faceless nameless people reading a
statement but representatives in
positions of power who were looking to
try and ameliorate the situation which
of course I found odd why why I reach
out to us now why did everyone refused
to talk to us when we were at the center
of this this national scandal that the
CEO of your company had to address
publicly when our livelihoods were on
the line why did we receive complete
radio silence
and now because of a throwaway cell
phone video direct contacts to the
higher-ups and assistance with our
channel seemed really odd but wanting to
act in in in good faith we opened
communications while we were still
conducting more research experiments
behind the scenes and yet the excuse
that we often hear and that you'll often
hear from YouTube is that all of these
results are based on algorithms that's
kind of been the crux of this is these
algorithms are designed really to best
serve the most relevant content to
viewing audiences that's the constant
defense obviously that didn't add up in
our case when people couldn't find our
content exclusively in the United States
so after the initial call the contacts
at YouTube were kind enough to switch
the status of our channel to show the I
believe it's called a prominent user
interface if I'm not mistaken and that
includes a channel card which identifies
our channel and a link to the SUBSCRIBE
at the top along with our videos and
suggested links column and we were
notified that that not everyone had
gotten this including some other
prominent channels this is important
because it proved two things one for the
first time okay
someone at YouTube was actually paying
attention and more importantly to that
ultimately there was a person or is a
person at YouTube who can make these
kinds of calls or at the very least can
correct and guide them as was the case
with our channel finally finally this
brings us to some evidence that we just
stumbled upon as it relates to the
current DNC primary election so many of
you have probably guessed where this is
going a lot of you may not but let me
start this with tulsi gabbard already
has a pending lawsuit with google /
YouTube alphabet for what she perceives
is unfair treatment now I want to let
Tulsi Gabbard explain the case in her
own words first I know that you had some
problems that you are contesting Google
did not treat you fairly after the last
debate yeah
about that look in the first debate I
was on the first night and I was the
most searched candidate of that event
unfortunately Google chose to
arbitrarily block our Google Ads account
for several hours at the time that was
most critical for our campaign I'm suing
Google for taking that action they've
provided no valid explanation for why
that was done there was no wrongdoing or
problem on our part not because of me
but because of this monopoly this power
that these big tech monopolies have to
simply shut out people arbitrarily this
is a threat to our freedom of speech and
it's an important thing for for us all
to stand united in calling out and to
protect because whether you're democrat
or republican or on the left or on the
right for a big tech monopoly to have
this power this affects all of us
ok it'll only be clear I don't really
agree with
tulsi gabbard on a whole lot I wouldn't
vote for if she were the candidate for
president but I can still tell right
from wrong her lawsuit let me be clear
about this in case you didn't fully
grasp it that centers around her being
blocked out from Google Adsense accounts
now what that is is an advertising arm
run by Google and YouTube allowing you
both to create and pay to promote ads or
videos as well as receive ads on your
channel ok two things here one I've also
experienced the exact scenario that
tulsi gabbard is describing we've run
ads here on YouTube for years ok now
what kind of ads we've really only run
ads where we run our videos as pre-roll
ads before other videos right you know
where you can click skip ad but although
people don't skip we just run our videos
and we've been doing it for a long time
I was approached by YouTube to do this
we don't run as many ads of course as
NBC Universal or disney viacom vice but
we do what we can now many of the ad
campaigns that we've run here on YouTube
through Google Adsense
we're actually engineered by YouTube
employees themselves again who reached
out to me and taught me how to create
these ads and encouraged me to spend
more money on these YouTube advertising
campaigns but at some point they decided
that these campaigns the ones they
initially created were now a violation
of policy and
locking them out not only that but even
though I was told the exact opposite I
had clearly been blacklisted from
promoting any of my videos on the
platform here so again I ran some tests
behind the scenes and I tried to pick
the most vanilla milquetoast examples I
could find of my videos and I attempted
to promote them as ads on the platform
like this this long-form conversation I
think is one with climate change
original Greenpeace member Patrick Moore
and then of course all the civil
productive changed my mind
segments all were declined all were
deemed shocking content again even
though YouTube had helped design
campaigns around these exact pieces of
content and collected hundreds of
thousands of dollars in advertising
those same videos years before so I say
this because I want you to know I'm well
aware of the screw jobs that can occur
with Adsense without any answer in this
cavern second point most importantly
this establishes a record with tulsi
gabbard of Google YouTube altering the
rules for a specific window of time when
tulsi gabbard was trending or was widely
searched due to a bump in the debates
you don't get that back so now we enter
the most what I would say is I would
argue the most troubling portion of all
this ok again please do tweet it out use
the hashtags Facebook Instagram in case
this gets removed is it still up are we
still up yeah we're still ok good so
good ish yeah on Friday Hillary Clinton
Rodham case you thinking of someone else
Hillary Rodham Clinton claimed that
tulsi gabbard well she claimed that
there were people who were Russian
assets and then it was confirmed that it
was Tulsi Gabbard right confirmed that
she was talking about Tulsi Gabbard
accusing her being a Russian asset and
Tulsa's response had her trending number
one on Twitter I think it was was us on
Friday it was last Friday that's when
we're looking into this ok so she was a
number one trend actually I think like
number one through four because one
might have been Tulsi another might have
been rushed an asset and another might
have been Gabbard the point is she was
the belle of the ball with many verified
check marks by the way in pundits
running with the story fighting over
whether she was a Russian plant so
during
time we decided to again while tulsi
gabbard was in the spotlight run some
comparative searches on youtube when we
set our VPN so want to be clear this is
the crescendo share it pirate this in
case it gets removed when we set our VPN
to a non United States country and we
search for Tulsi Gabbard her channel and
the videos from her channel all showed
up first yet again when we switched our
searches to the United States however
nothing exclusively in the United States
the country in which she is currently
running for president you would receive
no results from Tulsi gabbard's Channel
or her videos until scrolling past the
first page here's a video screen
recording in please just in case people
try to say that we've doctored it by the
way these video screen recordings will
be available as clips on YouTube should
you want to use them for articles so
that Friday you search she's trending
one on Twitter all of a sudden boom
valve is pinched you can't find her
exclusively United States you can't if
you're in Germany you can't if you're in
Spain United States however nothing by
Sunday once the trend of Hillary
Clinton's character assassination had
subsided the results for the US and
other countries were magically switched
back to being identical now it's worth
noting that her channel is right now as
far as I know it o mitad from both sets
of results so everyone out there take
some screenshots do some VPN experiments
I assume they're going to be fixing this
once this video is out and I assume that
someone there is watching this right now
so there may not necessarily be
consistent you don't always have the
same result twice even though that by
the way they're the same heard her
channel is not as prominent as it was
before let me say this tulsi gabbard is
not my candidate like i said i wouldn't
vote for but this this is chilling
especially when you consider let's think
about this for a second again we
stumbled across this accidentally i
don't know if anyone else has proof that
there is someone who flips a switch on
youtube to make your channel a part of
the preferred channels network whatever
the hell it's called we only found out
because of the fox had pocalypse and
then we only found out because i
separately
mentioned that this reeks of election
meddling all of a sudden the phone call
and someone says we've we've remedied
that scenario that means that if someone
can flip that switch and it's not
entirely algorithmic or it's almost as
though the algorithms are determined by
a human being initially it's not a robot
that means that same person can flip off
the switch for someone like tulsi
gabbard all of us is spine tink it is
hair-raising ly scary and if you're
interested in a fair election whether
for the presidency or just for the
Democratic candidate for the presidency
this should raise some major red flags
the influence that big tech has and
their willingness to manipulate
information in the face of what should
be a democratic election regardless of
whether it's happening to someone I
support or not is terrifying so let me
address some arguments by the way that I
know will be presented and I hope that
you are being skeptical of this I
encourage you to be and I encourage you
to run your own tests YouTube and Google
will inevitably claim one of three
things or several because this is what
we've run into this is always what they
claim publicly one that it's simply
algorithmic it's not again this channel
is singularly unique in that we're able
to prove that it's not because our
channel was fixed by someone manually
someone flipped a switch someone could
unfort Elsa Gabbard to YouTube may try
to pass this off as an accident a result
of a poor Laurel lower level employee
with bad judgment claiming that this was
an oversight and that the individual
didn't make the proper corrections and
they have since addressed the issue
don't buy that either okay why we've
been in direct contact with decision
makers at YouTube who are aware of these
problems and have been trying to do
damage control to fix the problems okay
it would stand to reason that the status
of a current presidential candidate who
is actively suing YouTube would be under
the same kind of close watch from the
world's biggest information and
technology company and that she wouldn't
be someone pod off pawned off on some
Patsy for the higher ups doesn't pass a
sniff test 3 this is another argument
though using this is most important
YouTube in the past has consistently
argued that their algorithms policies
that they are the results
well they argue that it's a result about
it but they do argue let me be clear
here
that the algorithms the policies the
results that you find are often
geographically dependent that's
something that we were told it's
something that many of
you have been told and that's because
it's geographically dependent because
it's designed to best serve viewing
audiences with the most appropriate
content for their search I've heard his
argument made a whole lot and I expect
it to be made now if that's the case I
would implore YouTube please because I
know someone I know someone there's
watching could you please explain to me
your shareholders and in all likelihood
a congressional hearing why you believe
it most appropriate in serving your
audience to block the content of the
United States presidential candidate
exclusively in the country in which she
is running how is that best serving
anybody in the same way how does it
serve the audience searching for steven
crowder change my mind to not show them
what it is that they are searching for
I'm sure shareholders and people who who
want to understand how these algorithms
and big tech work they would love to
know why it's in their best interest for
users to not find the content they
signed on for and are actively searching
how does allowing Tulsi gabbard's
channel and videos to show up everywhere
around the world except for the United
States best serve your audience YouTube
you are in the information business and
I want to clarify this when we say big
tech know it's the information business
right now from a business perspective
YouTube how does it make sense to
preclude your users from finding the
content they are searching for
specifically and passionately the only
answer I can come up with in the face of
mounting evidence is that it's not even
profit driven but to an extent
ideological and finally to the
detractors who I know will say well
Tulsi is not a serious candidate right
was here's what - in the grand scheme it
doesn't really matter Tulsi is not a
serious candidate okay you know what I
get it not very high in the polls people
just people's are the same thing about
us well it's just some right-wing edgy
channel who really cares well actually
it's the biggest conservative channel in
the history of the world's largest media
platform because of you and we are so
grateful I don't say that boastfully I
say that in a terrified from a place of
terror because who knows where we'll be
tomorrow
but the biggest conservative channel in
the platform they've actively tried to
silence it Tulsi Tulsi Gabbard is not a
serious candidate I hear that well let
me ask you a question what assume that's
true why do you think that is well if
they near the left talk about big money
in politics all the time right the Koch
brothers oil money and listen I think
it's a problem but the Koch brothers
opposed Donald Trump and money can't
save people from the viral news cycle in
2019 Donald Trump like it or not is the
new media president he can affect the
globe with his tweets that's why it's an
international scandal you can't buy that
Bernie Sanders didn't have the money or
the power the Clintons did and it took
everything they had to try and shut him
down
why because of the radical new media
landscape information in 2019 is more
valuable in elections than money and
right now
I am confident in saying that Tulsi
Gabbard is being barred from access to
or delivery of
necessary information sure listen we
don't know whether Tulsi Gabbard can get
the votes and be a winning candidate
I'll give you that just like we don't
know how large this very channel could
grow if there were a level playing field
let me paint a picture for you for
people to say well she's not a serious
candidate I'm asking you why let's run
this little thought experiment if back
in the 60s well let's even say early 50s
through the earth sorry late 50s through
early 60s back in the 60s JFK was
completely banned from appearing on the
only three main networks that existed
ABC NBC CBS right then after a certain
amount of time it was an Indian going oh
if he was banned from all of those
networks do you think he would have been
the Democratic candidate if he weren't
if he had never been allowed to appear
on those networks networks which which
reached I think twenty eight million
homes that was about yeah we have the
source here 60% of United States
household do you think that he would
have had the same fan base do you think
he would have been a serious candidate
on everyone's lips I would argue likely
not well let's compare that YouTube has
two billion monthly active users and is
used by 73% of you
States adults google has a 90 point four
six percent share of the market as it
relates to searches conducted on line
world wide it is far greater than the
influence of every television network
combined in the era of JFK or Nixon make
no mistake okay this is the most
powerful information company on the face
of the earth today and likely to have
ever existed and they've repeatedly
shown an inability and unwillingness to
invite to engage and sometimes they
ultimately just block people from even
having a seat at the table
we often hear folks say and this has
become a catchphrase like I said earlier
but in this instance I think this is
accurate it's it's truly not a left or
right issue this is a fundamental issue
that relates to the state of our
republic and I would hope that everyone
from The Young Turks to their
subsidiaries to Seth Meyers to John
Oliver to folks in the yang gang even
the toastie Gabbert followers themselves
who I know been asking questions if
she's been getting a raw deal hopefully
this helps you I would ask all of you
with whom I have very little in common
to see the gravity of this situation and
in this instance come together to demand
answers and transparency from the
world's largest information company as
it relates to free and fair elections I
will await YouTube's answers with bated
breath sorry it wasn't all that funny
because I had to make sure that I got
this out and then I didn't say anything
that held me legally liable that's why
my half-asian lawyer bill Richman is
here how are we good sir yeah so far
alright so far and please do again keep
this going we have some videos right now
right on Twitter court of like here we
have it prepped we did our due diligence
and the hashtags are hashtags are
Crowder exposed YouTube and I believe I
believe it's YouTube's 20/20 election
black jew-jew
2020 election blacklist and Crowder
exposes YouTube so I want to make sure
that you keep that going these
screenshots will be available to
everyone and to those who were asking we
said listen we think we're onto
something a lot of people behind the
scenes I know half-asian Larry bill
Richman had to deal with this poor guy
was pulling pulling his hair out but
he's got a thick mane
well can you get it to us we said now if
we get that if we get this info to you
now it's going to go public and someone
else is going to try to run with it and
they might not get the story right so
yes it's been a very stressful few days
but half-asian lawyer bill Richman your
thoughts so I think that people don't
necessarily if you kind of sum
everything up you've given them a lot of
information in order to be clear and to
be detailed and to really boil it down
tulsi already publicly knows and has
been publicly fighting since July when
she filed her lawsuit against Google and
YouTube to say that they had been
screwing with her on the Google ad side
and knowing that the ads are the way
that in this market and this current
economy and our current tech world how
we communicate to voters whether you're
on the left or the right whether you're
Republican or you're Democrat and she
already knows about that and that's the
same thing that we've had to deal with
in terms of our own ads being removed
and unable to actually do the kinds of
things that every other platform is able
to do with no clarity on the violations
so what the other parallels that we had
here and again that school kind of led
to where we are now is being able to see
that not only is it ads and ads her ads
are ads but it's also search for her and
search for us and that's the most
incredible part about this is you know
we looked at it and we we're very
skeptical you know to say hey would how
could this be true the spotlight is on
then why would they continue to do this
and so again there's someone there the
the kind of back-and-forth action makes
it clear that there is a person making
the decisions and I think your point is
very very key it's actually mentioned in
the amended complaint filed by Tulsi
Gabbard in her lawsuit against Google is
that algorithms are written by people
they are written with an intended
results they see the results and their
job is to monitor the results so if
anyone's out there thinking well you
know with all eyes on them surely they
didn't intend to screw with Tull cease
campaign and to screw with her ability
to rise in the polls to screw with her
ability to communicate to people on both
sides of the aisle about her candidacy
for the Democratic primary ticket one
still has to put the blame back on these
companies for not taking the action that
they could it would be kind of going
back to that first case if we don't look
together with Facebook remember it
wasn't you know up at the top they were
saying well we had no idea that there
was this
group of contractors who were supervised
by employees that had a written policy
that included a blacklist and you happen
to be on it and you know but it was an
accident right well you clearly in the
years that that's happened that excuse
no longer makes for people who don't
know that was when was it in gadget or
gizmo Gizmodo that's how patient larry
bill Richman and i initially met was
there was a list of people on facebook
to throttle to make sure that they're
there
really i think this was a list to make
sure that their their content wasn't
trending and it was like Breitbart
Drudge reports some conservative
organizations in yours truly for some
reason ago well this is really bizarre
and I reached out to half-asian lawyer
bill Richman the thing is at that point
they didn't argue it at all they just
argued that well this was these were
some rogue employees who did it and
we've corrected the problem and at that
point no one was really looking for it
right we just stumbled across this it
was actually a friend who was a drummer
at my wedding who introduced me to two
half-asian bill and a wonderful
friendship blossomed from there
that being said that can't be the case
here because this is a current
presidential candidate who is already
suing the company they wouldn't be able
to well we had no idea we passed her off
to some low-level employee if that's the
case then you're far too inept to be the
single biggest information delivery
company in the history of mankind and
there needs to be some more oversight
well and I think the other the other
question there is that when we saw the
Facebook situation remember there were
inquiries from the Senate from Congress
representatives we're reaching out there
was many statements that Facebook had to
make to explain and to try and give some
information and they were able to get
away without having to say too much
about exactly what had happened at that
time but had to really open the kimono
if you will and here there's really no
other answer that YouTube can give other
than to say we've got to look at all the
files and you've got to get a
congressional hearing I mean these are
the kinds of things where regardless of
the validity on the legal aspects of
Tulsa's lawsuit I know she's had to
switch from different claims and
actually just a week ago Google and
YouTube filed a lawsuit they filed a
motion to dismiss her entire claim now
they don't want to provide any
information they don't want to provide
any data they don't want to provide any
explanations even just on that issue so
for the time being blocked on her being
blocked by the way she doesn't know
about this
tulsi gabbard this would the this is
very new information no one as far as I
know
talk about this reveal this information
that while she was trending last week
being accused of being a Russian asset
you search anywhere not in the United
States Tulsi gabbard's content shows up
search in the United States ghosted she
doesn't know this well probably will be
reaching out after this and if you just
want to draw the parallels there on the
Friday that we discovered this on the
Friday that she was twenty that she was
trending because of Hillary calling her
a Russian backed groomed asset right
that was the day that YouTube filed its
motion to dismiss her claims so if
you're if you're asking as a consumer
you know just like you know companies
may try and use the law to be able to
skirt and be able to use the current
legal system to get away from answering
questions what they can't get away from
are the customers what they can't get
away from are the viewers and the
creators who want to know if I'm
regardless of political ideology if I'm
not the favored person am I gonna be
treated differently in here it's all
very clear that you know no one there
may be a lot of people who enjoy Tulsi
gabbard's frankness who enjoy her
service to this country but have very
differing views on her politically and I
think that's most of us on on this show
but that doesn't mean that we're again
in that classic line now we may not
agree with what you're saying but we'll
fight for your right to say it and
what's clear now is that YouTube is not
interested in fighting for your right to
say it if you happen to be in disfavored
Democratic candidate and I think where
we can also all find some common ground
we can all you know hold hands and sing
da who door hey around the Christmas
tree in agreeing that Tulsi Gabbard is
she's a good-looking lady good-looking
lady broch they'll throw this out due to
egregious sex is it cuz I said she's an
attractive woman we're bridging the
divide here no something else that's
also really odd to me as Tulsi Gabbard
is she's been tarred and feathered so
much she's really I mean she's pretty
far left she's only moderate as it
relates to free speech and she was the
one who named a cut-off when it came to
abortion at 28 weeks that's seven months
so I don't necessarily think she's a
radical pro-life or at that point right
but it is odd it's like why isn't her
stuff showing up why is this why is it
that been so stacked against her is it
because they want someone so much
further to the left and Gaby or could it
be this idea you know Hillary Clinton
might toss her hat back we have no idea
this is entirely conjecture it's just
weird to me that she's seen as a Russian
asset because of slightly conservative
views really libertarian views in that
she's a non interventionist and she
thinks she should
have an abortion after seven months is
that worth being blocked out its extreme
Steven that's extreme don't know well
it's it that is the craziest part about
this is there's so much unanswered and
there's only one company that has all of
those answers we can see the results
right we can see the physical search
results on how they get modified and we
can certainly extrapolate from that the
impact on not being able to have a voice
when you are the most trending topic on
Twitter in a very fast new cycle
surrounding a Democratic primary we can
see all of that but what we can't see is
the motivation or the mistakes that were
made and those are the answers that the
the people of the United States again
the people who don't get to see
tulsi gabbard or steven crowder show
when searching and results those are the
answers that need to be given right and
I want to be clear to full disclosure we
have spoken with YouTube in recent times
but those conversations are to be kept
confidential and we and know no point
discussed this with them tulsi gabbard
anything like this I just want to be
cratered yeah we have no I don't have to
say that legally like we didn't just
ghost all together with them I don't
know you're the lawyer am i good you're
good okay all right I just want to get I
don't want to get sued because you know
I use the wrong pronoun or something
like that and that's a violation of it
but I will say this I made myself
available but any of the I always get
confused whether it's committee or a
hearing when they do these when they
have these different studies so they
have committees they have subcommittees
most I don't know if every single
representative and senator is on a
various committee but I believe they are
and they are on maybe five six seven
sometimes even 10 or 12 and then those
committees will have certain powers and
subpoenas to call people down to ask
sometimes they just do it voluntarily
right because of the hey if you don't
want to if you don't want to show up
right Susan Wojcicki says hey I'm just
really too busy to answer questions
about you know influencing the
Democratic primary then that's an answer
in and of itself so there's a power
there that can be exercised and this is
if there are any aspects in which you
know you want to see the kind of coming
together like you saw with Ted Cruz and
AOC on some topics these are the kind of
topics because every side has these
questions well and I want to be clear we
haven't been available before but both
myself and half-asian lawyer bill
Richman we'll make ourselves available
if you need us to would it be tested
it could be it could be my maybe under
oath may be an okay well I want to make
sure that you guys understand to anyone
who might be watching again we've hosted
politicians here on this show senators
congressmen people who ran for people
who have run for president who might be
running for president there is no one
out there who has had the same kinds of
conversations relationships or the
overall plethora of evidence that we
have as it relates to YouTube because
we've had to deal with it on the Adsense
side we've had to deal with it in the
organic search side we've had to deal
with it on the D monetization side and
because of this we have been aggregating
so much research over the last several
decades we want to be clear this is not
us going oh it's censorship that's not
what we're talking about here we are
talking about dishonesty and misleading
business practice as it relates to our
case as it relates to Tulsi Gabbard
right now in this new evidence and we
are going to be searching from where we
encourage you to search for more and
send it all to us
it is very disconcerting to see the
amount of power that can be exerted over
if you want to call it just the election
but I think this goes far beyond the
election it goes to a shifting cultural
political landscape yeah really so let's
let's get rid of the top conservative
channels that exist and then let's get
rid of the moderate Democratic
candidates I'm not saying this is
exactly what's happening but I am saying
that undeniably you look at it is so odd
there's no answer for why our content
would show up in countries not called
the United States and why a United
States should get Tulsi Gabbard
congressman congressman senator
congresswoman I think she's a Congress
represent that which is it yes okay
represented why a United States Congress
woman would show up in in in Chile and
not the United States
none of the excuses we've heard thus far
would work it's algorithmic no it's not
were the only ones who would have proof
but it's not for a lot of these the idea
that there was an oversight low-level
employee no it's not she's suing and you
guys filed a motion to try and dismiss
this lawsuit so what's obviously on your
radar
then it's the idea that you want to most
appropriately serve content to people
who are sorry well how do you how are
you most appropriately serving the
audience by not showing them the results
from a sitting representative right now
running for United States presidency
exclusively and Gannett none of those
work these are the accusers that have
been trotted out before my guess is
he'll probably say oh you know what it
was a glitch that's still really bad if
you want to say that we fake
it great we welcome that too I really
just want to hear some answers at this
point we all want some answers and
there's a there's a very small window of
opportunity here to get this right
that's why I want to be clear we've been
talking with us for a long time our
interactions with YouTube and and our
legal issues and run-ins that we've
tried to play long ball and be as
transparent as possible as be as minimal
as possible as compromising as possible
when appropriate but right now if there
is something happening tipping the
scales of the election and this is so
ought we stumbled across its it's the
specific example that you out there
thought had been going on last election
cycle it was Bernie you thought that the
establishment was colluding against
Bernie this go-around
tulsi gabbard almost boycotted the last
debates because she thought they were
treating her unfairly and a lot of you
echoed that sentiment I can tell you
whether people are treating her unfairly
okay that remains to be seen as far as
how it relates to the information
delivered on the platform she is
absolutely being treated unfairly yeah
and I don't want any of these people to
be president I want to be crystal clear
some of those things because I've said
that Tulsi Gabbard is hot that I want to
know I don't want her to be President
Adri I don't know absolutely pulled it
pull that lever every day for Trump and
twice on Sunday
but I want and this is a big thing too I
want it to be an honest win when
President Trump beats whatever candidate
it is and I want that national election
that general to also be honest I don't
want Democrats to not be able to get a
candidate say what you want about
president Donald Trump he was the
candidate people wanted you can't say
that he was pushed by the Illuminati or
the Koch brothers none of them liked
this guy they all thought he was gonna
burn it down its first any of
Republicans who went never Trump right
there was a huge divide he is the
candidate that the people wanted and the
people who voted for him loved him even
though I disagree with Democrats
liberals on almost everything in 2019
not back to JFK but today I still want
you to be able to have the candidate
that you have selected through a process
that should remain untainted I want it
to be an honest win not a cheat you know
I think one of the one of the questions
that that we were looking at and that I
know you've been kind of doing some
research on if you can recall the
numbers
comparing the the Russian meddling
scandal to this yes and I think from
just a sheer dollars comparison it was a
few thousand dollars of ads from from
Russian assets in actual Russian assets
yeah you know trying to influence the
leverage can probably get that to me
Reggie I know you're in the other room I
think it was three thousand something
and so you compare three thousand
dollars and three thousand dollars of
ads for tulsi gabbard would be the ads
that she would probably run in just a
few minutes trying to reach the platform
of a Democratic candidate for this
primary and so when you compare those
different numbers and you look at the
impact here there is a incredible
question and that's one thing that's
interesting in that motion the YouTube
filed they talk about well she admits
that it was just a few hours well just a
few hours in a 24-hour news cycle it can
be a lifetime I mean that can be
millions of views ignore millions of
messages about the few hours after the
debate it's not even close
exactly and that in comparing the
circumstances there and how oak
conveniently she's back up on Sunday
while everyone else is watching football
or a church yeah well especially
actually even right now we're top 10
trending I believe in the in the United
States you can't buy that that's can I
guess Samsung has but they spend a ton
of money and it doesn't last very long
and then their then their phones explode
but the point is this kind of overall
publicity right is something that people
can't necessarily buy I think it was I'm
pretty confident saying it was thirty
five hundred dollars in ads Russian
Facebook ads how much do you think let's
do this how much do you think Russia
would pay if they could guarantee that a
candidate who they saw is the greatest
threat let's just say for an example I'm
not saying Tulsi Gabbard is greater
certain know people gonna say a plant
just stop
if someone what's remove the Russians
let's say it's the Chinese sorry half
asian bill if someone wanted to to stack
the deck of the election right how much
do you think they would be willing to
pay to guarantee that the most
threatening candidate was not turning up
in any organic search algorithms match
Agra just shutting Tulsi Gabbard out and
us by the way but Tulsi Gabbard out this
is about tell this is tell cease party
it's not us will come back we have some
more info
for you eventually unstuff going on
without you too but right now it's about
it's about Tulsi she's earned this how
much wood would you think that these
people would pay to ensure that let's
say Donald Trump Hillary Clinton who
ever it is doesn't show up when you
search for them it's a transaction ok
behind closed doors did we I do not want
Donald Trump to show up in search all
right well what do you want to pay for
that if you guarantee do you guarantee
that he won't show up if someone
searches name in united's what if they
search it in Germany I don't give [ __ ]
about Germany what about what about in
Dagestan I don't give a rat's ass about
Dagestan
but if search in United States how can
you guarantee me that their channel will
not show up for at least one or two page
because we have numbers that show people
do not search beyond first page and if
YouTube said we guarantee you that
Donald Trump or we guarantee you that
Tulsi Gabbard will not show up I will
pay insert how many millions that you
want here at least eight figures and you
add that up the totality of the election
span that's absolutely insane we're not
just talking about blocking her out from
running ads which anyone else can do
we're talking about the organic
algorithms tipping the scales against
her and the worst part is if you're
fighting ghosts you're fighting ghosts
and there's no accountability they don't
have to answer it's amazing to me that
they don't can they legally with Tulsi
Gabbard well they legally be able to
dismiss it and just not provide any
answers as to why she was blocked out
from advertising there's a judge who's
gonna look at all the arguments make the
decisions they have a new Tull C's team
hasn't even had the opportunity to file
the response I mean the motion was just
filed on Friday again the day that her
search results for blah right in the
United States while she was trending
number one in the United States but once
ultimately the the core of the are the
arguments are there and and frankly any
ability to not get the answers from the
lawsuit is an indictment of our current
statutory system that would allow a
company like YouTube or allow a company
like Facebook to be able to say hey
we're just a platform people just send
messages they post what they're gonna
post we don't edit those contents we're
not a publisher we're not a broadcasting
studio subject
to other restrictions and what's clear
here is that their action that they're
taking separate and apart from the the
more egregious sin of interfering with
the election with a specific candidate
is the issue of whether or not they are
on one side or the other of that
publisher platform divided and what
everyone continues to ask when they
continue to get pressed on but don't
give clear answers is which is it just
pick one I almost don't think I mean
this is me not and I'm not a lawyer but
the fact that Google and YouTube hosts
debates themselves seems to me that that
would enter the equation that they're no
longer just a neutral platform where
people had tend to go to watch debates
rooms when it's actually hosted by
Google YouTube and people are sending in
questions from Google YouTube that's
right all see was going to protest the
protests the last debate because she was
saying she thought she was treated
unfairly by Google that's got to open
the door to some higher standard I think
all of those different factors go into
play because it's a pretty complex
analysis to decide are you four on one
side of the divide or other or the other
but when you add all of this up together
it creates a scenario that's hard to
deny when you're determining what ads
are going to be placed when you're
determining what people can say whether
they're advertising a business or not or
it's political ads if you're changing
what people can find and how easy it is
for them to subscribe or get
notifications if you're making it
difficult for people to be able to find
you in search results or to find you and
suggested feeds I think by definition
somewhere along there you cross the line
into being an editor and when you've
edited the content and you become an
editor of content that whole landscape
shifts and that's not even to get into
the idea of the paid partnership program
and monetization where YouTube applies
different rules as far as and I would
imagine the same applies in running ads
where they say well not everyone has a
right to post on YouTube but not
everyone has a right to be a part of a
partner to be pinned and at that point
your seems like you're venturing well
into the realm of publisher because you
are determining who can and who can't
make money off of you which is fine I'm
fine with but again there needs to be
some sort of transparency there in my
opinion you are the lawyer
all right the hashtags we're gonna go
we'll keep you updated hopefully we hear
some something back hopefully you hear
something back look for this statements
in the public and look for those three
arguments that they always make they
don't hold water that it's just an
algorithm it's not there's a person it
was some low-level employee it
absolutely couldn't be or the idea that
the algorithms best serve the audience
you tell me how you best serve the
audience by not serve
Americans information regarding a
current American running for president
who's also a current United States
representative look for those three
arguments and immediately dismiss them
and ask for another answer and please
run your own searches not just Tulsi
Gabbard not just even credit changed my
mind but other presidential candidates
political topics the only way that this
gets out there the only way that this
gets corrected is of course legally and
like we said we will make ourselves
available for any hearings or cross
examinations or whatever legal terms
bill knows yes what you're about to say
I was gonna say for those who are
skeptical and I know this is gonna get
out further than just our normal kind of
right leaning or conservative here's
this this will hit all the different
types of groups in America in case
you're just not concerned about a
conservative or a not liberal enough
candidate being restricted on YouTube
and maybe you think that's okay I would
ask you to go back and look at the
different lawsuits complaints that were
made against YouTube and Google and
Facebook for complying with the
restriction of LGBT content of other
left-leaning content in countries like
Saudi Arabia or China or Russia or other
countries like that the power that they
have is acknowledged they acknowledged
using the power and now we have evidence
that they're using it to interfere with
an election yeah and I would I would say
I was about to go and I felt like I was
on a roll but I think it's such a good
point and I even though I know it's
really easy for a lot of people out
there to demonize us because you know we
have a shirt that says socialism for
figs and you say we don't really care no
love lost if we're gone from the channel
for big tech companies who talk about
their philanthropy and talk about being
able to effect positive change on a
global scale right and so it's easy to
hate us because you think well we make
jokes therefore it must be if there's a
racially charged joke it must mean that
someone is racist or if we're
conservative it must mean that we're a
Nazi right think about what this means
overall for not just LGBTQ but people in
other countries who are still fighting
for their civil rights who are still
fighting for their rights to access
information freely if you have the
biggest tech monopolies tripolis if
that's a word working with governments
to enforce their policy or to dictate
what governments are installed and I
would also ask what possible altruistic
argument could be presented here right
now it's easy to say well Stephen
shouldn't
Gladys Crowder Stephen credit shouldn't
be on YouTube okay fine it's easy to say
I don't know dennis prager shouldn't be
on YouTube because he's one of those in
Nazi rabbis okay fine
but how do you say you know what
morally were justified in making sure
that people who are searching for Tulsi
Gabbard don't find in the United States
that's the right thing to do
I just don't see a moral case even if we
disagree on everything and I don't see
moral case because I don't see it as a
moral decision to ever silence voices of
dissent simply because you can even
though it's unethical and it's what you
claim to not do but I get it that's just
me that's my worldview but I don't see
how anyone even from a leftist world you
at this point could look at this
scenario and say yeah that's the right
thing to do because I don't like her
there's nothing good about this here
folks nothing and I also don't want you
I don't want you to assassinate the mess
again I'm not a toast yeah but person
she might not even want to come on the
show to talk about this because people
scare her off and if you're afraid to do
the show you don't have to do the show
but I want this info to get out to as
many people as possible please keep a
trending posted right aren't radicals I
know we have a visit Crowder exposes you
to but is it up 2020 election blacklist
yep
YouTube 2020 election Blackwell and I I
encourage you comment we're gonna leave
this stream up anything any upside that
you can see to this happening right now
I I don't I I fail to see it and I try
to the reason we do devil's advocate on
this show and the reason we do change my
mind is because if I firmly believe if
you cannot argue your ideological
opponents position you have no business
holding your own I can't I cannot make
the case for why any of this is
justifiable and not happening to me but
happening to other people right now most
notably Tulsi Gabbard if someone can
make that case I would love to hear it
we'll keep you abreast as it relates to
our channel specifically and our content
there likely won't be a show tomorrow I
think we have Rand Paul on the program
live on Thursday 8:00 p.m. Eastern thank
you so much I appreciate you bringing
with us I'm gonna go back to hopefully
just just doing comedy because I'm not a
news breaker it's not my strong suit
this
this this fell in my lap and I didn't
want it alright we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]